where did you get cadavers I don't blame
you guys for not understanding because
you guys haven't seen the amount of tylo
PES courses that I've seen I've made a
video reacting to on professional
medical tik toks
how about funny ones I'm sure there's
some funny ones out there let's go
searching this is questionable honestly
the first time you do an ultrasound it
is confusing I can relate to that
struggle ahead jelly it's just so cold
when it hits their skin problem Oh No am
I gonna die no your fingers broken I did
not expect that people are so much
whittier than I am that's so good I
thought she was gonna make a joke about
fibromyalgia and I was gonna get upset
like you shouldn't make fun of patients
and she said your finger that's really
good also there's a play on that doctors
joke where it's like doctor hurts when I
do this okay don't do this copay hi I'm
dr. Jones I'm an OBGYN physician I'll
tell you what I did stay but you have to
listen fast and put on a mask because
koban I got some coffee because I'm
addicted to caffeine after that I went
to the operating room into two surgeries
one major one minor before having
socially distance chips for lunch and
doing an HSG I'll tell you that is
another day I went to my clinic and soft
patients pregnant and not pregnant and
then I went to my office and I charted
forever and then I went to labor and
delivery and we delivered a baby and it
was super fun and now I'm going home
because I'm mama dr. Jones is a champ
not only because of everything she does
in her life and doing it quite well
she's amazing at tick tock it's a really
good representation of how hard it is to
be a doctor especially one who's seeing
patients in a clinic setting but also as
a surgeon it's not an easy life mama dr.
Jones ups a challenge if you haven't
seen our collapse I'm linking it down
below
I'm the one who should be upset I had to
go on break right after you know how
hard it is to eat a sloppy joe after
seeing the did he go quick or not he
took his time with my hurry up I'm
trying to go on break he fighting I'm
like let go man you got got on hold did
he suffer most definitely because he was
screaming I'm like man that's annoying
cuz I know that the patient's trying to
sleep I'm on the phone trying to talk to
my shirts agency trying to get my
insurance normally he and they can't
hear me on my show it makes you feel
better
I'm sure mr. Johnson is in a better ways
my dad's last name is Wilson
are you mr. Johnson son yo your dad is
dead oh thank you welcome that was rub I
have to say name mistakes in hospitals
do happen like this is a real issue in
fact when we have two people either with
the same last name or a last name that
sounds similar we put on our floors name
alerts like it says name alert above the
patient's bed and when you enter the
room so that these mistakes don't happen
and when people are creating the
person's chart it has a name alert on it
it's like a bright sticker so that
you're checking the right person's name
hey doctor well what's that thing
great question young man that would be
the heart hey Doc scalpel of course
doctor I was wondering if that was the
right coronary artery no that is a
circumflex artery get out vor some
doctors especially surgeons can be quite
mean to residents and students but
they're really nice to those who are
shadowing trying to decide whether they
want to go into the field because they
don't want to scare them away plus it's
also fair to say that they're under no
obligation to know all the important
arteries that person did ask what that
is it was the heart the one thing that I
will say with quite certainty and it's
all jokes aside is we need to end a
toxic culture of like attacking
residents and students that if they
don't know something they're done when
they're evil we need to kick them out
that doesn't really work it doesn't
motivate you to do better it actually
kind of puts you down and demotivates
you it's no good for anybody by harvard
days when my peak thought those days
were fun after mom's right you got a
medical school I actually didn't go to
school I learned everything I know
through YouTube tutorials and ebooks no
no I'm serious like I literally don't
have a legal medical degree because
everything that I was born
in school I was like I mean just learn
this on my own that's why I did I
studied on my own and I worked on
cadavers out of my garage like the Mark
Zuckerberg of dr. people where did you
get cadavers how are you the medical
director at a Children's Hospital it's
illegal to operate that a license is it
illegal to save a dying child's life
yeah for you it is dr. Welsh where did
you get cadavers I don't blame you guys
for not understanding cuz you guys
haven't seen the amount of tylo peds
courses that I've seen oh my god
honestly there's a lot you can learn
online and I feel like I'm about to
release some bird soon some limited
edition merch about how much education
you can get online specifically from
watching my videos but so far this is
hilarious let's keep playing knowledge
will take you so far in life without a
college degree for example every child
that I save represents a new Lamborghini
that comes into my life which is why I
have 43 Lamborghinis in my garage
you took tylo pest courses to learn how
to be an open heart surgeon gary
vaynerchuk was also a very large head
coach the president's daughter has a
punch today order dr. wulc get in that
operating room and save the president's
daughter's life but uh yeah medicine is
one of those things where why am I even
explaining this yeah you can't practice
medicine without a license and it's not
because like the license is some kind of
magical paper that actually proves
you're capable but when you're gonna
you're about to trust someone with your
health you hope that they've been
experienced Dave practice they've
learned they show competency in these
fields so yeah you want someone who's
not only showing you a medical school
diploma but also a residency graduation
certificate a board certification like
I'm a board certified family medicine I
have a medical license in New York and
New Jersey they ask you a lot of
questions about criminal backgrounds
where did this guy get a cadaver as
funny as that is that's not what happens
dude if we sat and watch Spongebob or
whatever for 45 minutes before going to
see patients we would be five hours late
to each patient think about it this way
I go into a room with the patient
technically I'm scheduled for 15 minutes
my nurse has to be in there for the
first five minutes gathering the chief
complaint asking some base
questions doing the vitals that's five
minutes now I have ten minutes with the
patient let's say it walk-in exactly on
time I introduce myself to the patient I
ask them what they're here for I ask
them their name I do a proper greeting
to make sure that we're on the same page
I ask him what's bothering them I ask
some follow-up questions I figure out
how long it's been an issue what other
things running their family I look at
their prescription medications I decide
to do a physical exam do a few things to
make sure I'm ruling out conditions that
could be otherwise threatening to their
health and to figure out what exactly I
think could be going on I then sit onto
the computer and I explain to them what
is going on I explain to them my
treatment plan I make sure they
understand I have them repeat back to me
the same set of instructions so we're on
the same page I then place the orders in
the computer so that they have their
medications ready or treatment ready
when they leave the office I then go
back to my area waiting to see the next
patient how much time do you think has
gone by I didn't even begin to write
this patient's note and I can't really
wait to do it at the end of the day
because then I'll get home way later
than I'm supposed to and everyone's mad
because I'm missing schedules I'm being
late to the next patient and it creates
a huge hurdle the amount of
administrative work that doctors had now
have to do is beyond anyone's
imagination like spending 30 minutes
making sure that my patient gets their
medication because I order capsules
instead of tablets happens way too often
that's why we're late not because we're
watching Spongebob oh that is cuter and
funnier to think about all right so Chad
looks like you've a minor tear on your
bicep nothing too severe but whenever
you take about a month off from any
physical activities we'll bring you back
in we'll reevaluate you and then we'll
clear you based off of how well you've
recovered okay sounds good the funny
part is I love that he's a Bengals fan
shut up Cincinnati folks this happens a
lot
most commonly where it's happened is
around sporting events like if someone's
training for the New York City Marathon
they come in with a serious injury
sometimes even though it's something
really serious like a stress fracture
I'm like do not run under any
circumstances because you could fracture
your shin bone completely and people are
just like I don't care I've been
training so long I'm doing it that's
obviously against medical advice you
they end up hurting themselves nice f
injuries those can be quite painful a
minor one yeah no big deal but I've seen
bicep tears where the bicep actually
ends up like up here that hurts don't
tear your bicep
check out these wildly absurd Instagram
health posts that I react to here or if
you want a good laugh
check out my most recent memes video
click here for that one more on this one
which one you're clicking on stay happy
and healthy
[Music]